[Music]
well good evening welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight a caravan of more than a
thousand Central Americans men women and
children is traveling across Mexico
tonight Mexican authorities are speeding
them toward their destination which is
our country our southern border these
are not refugees they are border jumpers
they have no legal right to come here
and that's about the sum total of what
we know about them at this point we
don't know if they have skills that we
need whether they speak English whether
they're gang members we know nothing
here's really know about us they know
that if they can cross the border into
California they're set Democratic
politicians in that state will shelter
them and give them benefits from
California they can go anywhere in this
country just like millions and millions
before them over the past 30 years if
you're wondering why America is not
anything like the country you grew up in
this is why well anyone empower do
anything to protect America this time or
while leaders sit passively back as the
invasion continues over the weekend and
earlier today the president sent a
series of tweets that seemed to reflect
frustration quote act now Congress he
tweeted at one point our country is
being stolen well to that official
Washington scoffed how dared the leader
of our country pretend that we have the
right to determine who comes here what a
racist here's Jim cheeto a former Obama
political appointee who now poses as a
journalist over at CNN watch as though
often happens with issues like this we
enter a fact free zone I mean you got a
fact check the president is I mean first
of all you saw you heard that FoxNews
rhetoric an army of migrants and it's
not an army it's a caravan it's a group
of folks who are seeking asylum the
president tweeted there are caravans as
if they're there are multiple groups of
people kind of storming the border
that's not true it's see it's one group
just a group of folks seeking a sound
more propaganda from the Obama people
pretending to be reporters
shut up America that's the message you
have no right to complain
that's CNN's view which means it's the
left view as well is it America's view
to voters agree do voters think that we
have a moral obligation to admit every
single person from around
world anytime who wants to come here
feed and house and educate them at our
expense
even as our own middle-class dies maybe
voters do think that I guess we'll find
out in the midterm elections this will
help to find those elections
Jessica Vaughn is director of policy at
of studies rather at the Center for
Immigration Studies and she joins us
Jessica thanks for coming on so when the
Obama guy over at CNN describes them as
just a group of folks seeking asylum
where does that leave the United States
does that mean that we can do nothing
about this well if they're seeking
asylum what they should be doing is
seeking it in the first safe country
that they come to which is Mexico in
this case that's not what this is this
is this is a political stunt designed to
challenge the United States and
particularly the Trump administration
that this is organized by activists it's
a walkathon for open borders they know
exactly what they they're doing they've
recruited these people to join this
group making their way to the United
States it's definitely a public
relations stunt but and it's a challenge
to our sovereignty and the president
needs to meet this challenge and not
just carry on the way the Obama
administration did and welcome them in
we don't need to accept their asylum
applications heck they're being trained
on how to commit Asylum fraud so I mean
this is a thousand people but why
wouldn't it be a hundred thousand people
or 300 thousand people I wouldn't be the
whole population of Salvador the
two-thirds that don't already live here
I mean at some point that's going to
happen because populations in poor
countries are exploding and what exactly
is our recourse when that does happen
what do we do to prevent that from
happening exactly well that's why we
have to present prevent it from
happening now there's a reason this has
been building to this point since the
Obama administration essentially changed
the rules on asylum and since friendly
judges stepped in and said you can't
detain kids they can be used as
deportation shields one thing we could
do is prevent them from getting to the
United States and and do as we've done
in the past and tell Mexico we want to
come in
and head this off before they get to our
border and you know we have a lot of
leverage with Mexico particularly on
migration issues it's not their job to
control our border but we can make it in
their interest to help us prevent things
like this from happening because let's
face it Mexico gets a lot more out of
our bilateral migration relationship
than we do so we need to use that
leverage maybe you know kind of tie it
into NAFTA if we have to but we don't
need to just sit back and stand by while
people take advantage of our of our lack
of a secure border right so 16 emergency
died last year from drug ODS and most of
those drugs came from Mexico so there
are a hostile country there abetting the
movement of these people here would it
be impossible to send the military to
our border I mean why is this not
honestly why is this not a hostile act
against our country it is I mean it
should certainly should be taken that
way we could invoke emergency you know
say that declared that this is an
immigration emergency that requires
extraordinary measures the federal
government has a plan for how to deal
with a mass migration emergency we've
done it before say when the Haitian boat
people came we sent the Coast Guard out
to intercept them there are tools and
authorities that the president has that
can be brought to bear here perhaps even
work with the state of Texas depending
on where they decide to to try to make
landfall in the United States we can
move money around there are authorities
we can take advantage of and we can use
our leverage with Mexico we don't have
to just sit back and wait for them to
arrive well somebody better be thinking
this through right now because this is
imminent Jessica thank you for that I
appreciate it